annie est-il que l'on a vu réagir sur
les réseaux sociaux député de l'oise
groupe u10 et indépendant bonsoir ramier
style merci d'être avec nous en direct
par téléphone la méthode repas qui a
donc été adoptée par l'assemblée
aujourd'hui vous vous dénoncez en gros
une antichambre de gpa qu'est-ce-qui
qu'est ce qui vous gêne il ya tromperie
on vous clairement de la part du
gouvernement oui bonjour tout assurer le
maintien je persiste et signe c'est une
forme de gpa qu'est ce que l'art palais
nos concitoyens non non non non pas
conscience j'étais dans un couple de
femmes clairement à ton là la femme a et
la femme b la femme b qui n'est pas
stérile qui pourrait que qui ne présente
aucune série litée porte l'enfant issu
des ovocytes de sa compagne la femme a
et évidemment des spermatozoïdes de
donneurs voilà en clair évidemment on me
dise et altruiste c'est pas pour
quelqu'un d'étranger c'est pour eux
mêmes mais c'est tout de même porter un
enfant qui n'est pas le sien qui un prêt
d'utérus
évidemment il n'y a pas de contrat mais
c'est évidemment vous dites
l'antichambre c'est une forme de gpa
là j'étais assez gestation pour autrui
c'est à dire porter un enfant pour un
autre alors on dit c'est pas un autre
chez eux mais mais mais c'est l'autre
femme imaginez qu'il y ait séparation
entre les deux la seule différence c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de contrat j'ai c'est la
seule différence avec une gpa donc dans
en 2025 on peut savoir qu'ils nous
diront la gpa éthique parce que la
différence avec la gpa tous courir gpa
éthique ce sera le manque de contrats
ont décrit altruiste c'est par amour
pour l'autre mais c'est une forme de gpa
je maintiens oui alors la majorité vous
a répondu on l'a vu dans le petit sujet
précédent disant non non ça existe je
les hétérosexuels mais clairement on
vous il ya une forme de tromperie
sciemment de la part de la majorité
aujourd'hui
bien sûr bien sûr dont on sait
parfaitement aux fêtes majorité veut
aller il veut continent en 2020 en 2025
la prochaine révision de loi bioéthique
ce sera pour la gpa nous
ont échappé de très près pour pour la
gta pour personne tranchant pour la gpa
post mortem
ils font le minimum deux semaines de
sorte qu'on puisse passer après le reste
ça c'est un premier pas vers eux vers la
gpa l'argument ne tient pas la route
l'argument comme donnant réponse
d'ailleurs a été aussi voté la gp11 pour
les enfants nés à l'étranger une
reconnaissance alors alors pareil qu'est
ce que c'est ça ce sont des personnes
qui ont bravé la loi du pays inquiets
qui la gpa est illégale en france
il voulait tout de même en faire donc
ils ont bravé la loi du pays donc c'est
quelque chose qui est interdit en allant
à l'étranger pour le faire parce qu'à
l'étranger
c'est permis et ensuite ils reviennent
en france mais on nous dit il faut
sécuriser l'enfant mais il n'y a pas
besoin de ces durées des enfants il est
tout un sécuriser l'enfant
il a un acte de naissance américains
c'est en réalité c'est pour aider et
faciliter la vie des parents mais
l'enfant lui il a un acte d'essence
américains et c'est tout à fait bien
simple on est toujours là dans
satisfaire le désir d'adultes et jamais
au grand jamais on ne pense aux enfants
l'enfant et les aider sécurisé n'a pas
de problème l'enfant fait c'est encore
pour aider les adultes
je voudrais qu'on pense beaucoup plus
aux os enfants on ne pense pas aux
enfants
on ne fait que satisfaire un désir
d'adultes
nous sommes en train de construire une
grande société gouvernée par les seuls
désirs individuels à la niacine ce qui
retient l'attention c'est que finalement
aujourd'hui ça n'a pas vraiment fait les
gros titres de la presse par quelques
articles d'ailleurs aucun membre du
gouvernement n'était présent pour cet
examen de ce projet de loi bioéthique
par la commission spéciale de
l'assemblée nationale ça dit quoi ça dit
que finalement c'est une loi qui mérite
pas plus de débat que ça je dis que
c'est absolument scandaleux vraiment
scandale et c'est une loi qui remet en
cause tout le droit de la filiation qui
va faire naître des enfants sans père
n'est ce pas qu'ils s'en foutent signé
des au logis le leur et leur idéologie
ça leur plaît pas mais c'est la suivante
c'est qu'il considère que le père est
une fonction
c'est à dire que ça peut être assumée
par n'importe quelle personne une
voisine un voisin n'ont qu'une grand
mère que sais-je aurore nous considérons
que le père n'est pas une fonction que
le père est un homme ça change tout
c'est une loi qui est qui qui changent
vous dit le droit de la filiation il ya
effectivement les les la recherche sur
l'embryon des embryons chimérique aussi
vous savez c'est ce ce mélange c'est du
lso anima animal et séduit mène mais au
niveau de la pma en tant que législateur
nous allons faire venir sciemment des
enfants orphelins de père tout de même
est ce que c'est notre rôle ça pose de
grandes questions est ce qu'on est là
pour satisfaire le désir personnel ou
pour légiférer pour un corps social
parce qu'à force de satisfaire des
désirs personnels
c'est la loi du plus fort chacun tire de
son côté nous nous sommes en train de
dévier au niveau législatif pour
satisfaire une poignée d'individus se
cette fête cet individualisme nous
conduira à des endroits où on ne veut
pas aller mais c'est scandaleux aucun
membre du gouvernement en ce moment la
priorité après cette grosse crise du
coville devra être l'emploi devrait être
l'économie et pas du tout la bioéthique
pas du tout demandez aux à la population
si c'est si la priorité c'est de faire
venir des enfants sans père ou de
considérer que le père est une fonction
est pas un homme mais ils ont la
préoccupation doit être ailleurs on nous
annonce peut-être plus de 22% du chômage
dans l'oise et je vais je airbus la à
toulouse et nantes promet aussi quelques
chômeurs c'est pas du tout une priorité
or or chat touche des sujets éthiques
d'une importance capitale qui touche les
êtres humains on est en train de faire
une loi
merci agnès six en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur arte france